au large des anses d'arlet la police de
la mer prend en chasse un scooter des
mers rasant les falaises l'utilisation
de ces embarcations est strictement
interdite de nuit de plus la vitesse
autorisée dans la zone des 300 m est
largement dépassé 30 48 59
le pilote et son passager sont prêts à
prendre tous les risques pour ne pas se
faire attraper
la tension est palpable sur le bateau
des affaires maritimes
à cette vitesse la moindre fausse manip
est fatale lumières éteintes les fuyards
vont réussir à s'évanouir sur l'eau
vous avez eu la manoeuvre qu'il a fait
il ay lama il a ralenti pour tourner
violemment il a éteint ses lumières
bleues là qui nous permettait de le
suivre
donc effectivement ben quand on est face
à des gens qui sont déterminés c'est
difficile à grands pas et bien sûr les
amener à faire des bêtises
la nuit risque d'être longue pour la
patrouille des affaires maritimes dans
la baie des anses d'arlet la fête bat
son plein sur les catamarans ancrer les
plaisanciers qui se déhanche pourraient
être contrôlés
mais ce soir ce sont d'autres
infractions que traquent la direction de
la mer dans la bande des 300 mètres la
vitesse est limitée à 5 noeuds pressé de
rentrer à bon port certaines
embarcations enfreignent les règles
c'est le cas de ce bateau qui naviguait
à près de 8 fois la vitesse autorisée
[Musique]
j'avais juste les arguments du jeune
homme seront sans effet une sanction
administrative un retrait de permis
d'une semaine
les infractions aux règles de navigation
sont plus lourdement sanctionné
finissent généralement au tribunal
maritime
quand les contrevenants sont des
professionnels ce bateau avait lui aussi
dépassé la vitesse autorisée
de plus aucun membre de l'équipage ne
peut présenter un permis récent chacun
permis valable jusqu'au 19 mars
il dit avoir peur à voir son permis mais
pas l'avant de ne pas l'avoir sur lui
donc moi je vérifierai s'il a
effectivement un permis en cours
sinon ce ne sera pas un simple défaut de
présentation du permis mais
une des fautes thermique carrément terme
de sanction se ferait juste de la prison
ça peut aller jusqu'au retrait des
diplômes après avoir joué la carte de la
sensibilisation les affaires maritimes
privilégie désormais la répression trois
accidents récents illustrent le
comportement irresponsable de certains
propriétaires de bateaux et beaucoup
d'infractions et de diverses natures
sont assez graves dans le défaut de feu
c'est grave
obligation nuit des jet skis c'est grave
des infractions chez les pros final
c'est grave parce qu'ils sont
professionnels et ans qui devrait encore
plus responsable que les autres j'ai
expliqué tout au lond assurer qu'on
avait eu trois blessés en une semaine et
que c'était trop et il fallait vraiment
que chacun soit responsable fasse preuve
de responsabilité sinon eh ben on
risquerait d'ailleurs de d'atteindre un
principe qui sont chères au maroc et la
liberté des mers
dans la seule journée d'hier une
douzaine de suspensions de permis ont
été effectués les affaires maritimes
envisage d'autres opérations de nuit
dans l'espoir que les comportements
changent enfin sur l'eau